credit card debt is exploding in this
country for the first time in American
history Americans as a whole on more
than a trillion dollars just to credit
card companies that's eight thousand six
hundred bucks for every household in
this country more than three grand for
every single man woman and child in
America including babies and that's just
credit cards millions of Americans also
have student loans home loans car loans
plenty of other debt are we reaching a
tipping point for debt and what would
happen if the economy enters another
downturn not that that would ever happen
when our Hawkins is chief macro
strategist Tammy Tammy tip kau you tell
me how to pronounce Alan or too many
vowels for me to madacorp research and
she joins us tonight and I'm glad you're
laughing because this is a terrifying
this is a terrifying subject
particularly the credit card deck
because it's something that everyone can
relate to you sort of understand how it
works if you're a consumer these levels
seem very high to me are they they're
very high what's even more concerning is
the pace at which were accumulating it
and in fact the last three months of
2017 consumers racked up credit card
debt at a faster pace than in all in the
past thirty years
so faster than even in the Great
Recession it just it seems like this is
one of those stories that is never
covered but it ought to be so here you
have some of the biggest companies in
the world getting kids on credit cards
in college charging rates that banks
would never chart I'm gonna start legal
for banks to try mean I had my step pull
this so the BP Visa card what's the
what's the interest rate twenty eight
point two percent interest isn't
supposed to be yeah well it's shocking
action its user II it's illegal in other
countries why is that happening here and
no one's saying anything because people
don't seem to have much of a choice
these days and if you look at what
hourly earnings have been decade after
decade after decade they've been growing
at a slower and slower pace people are
barely making ends meet and if you look
at like the past six out of the past
seven months hourly earnings have
actually been either flat
or they've fallen so people aren't
really making much money but then you
look at spending spending still growing
pretty fast
income isn't growing really fast what
are you gonna do well you're gonna take
these credit cards and you get desperate
well this is an age-old problem and when
the Mafia used to do this in the
immigrant neighborhoods among Sicilian
immigrants basically the exact same
thing credit card companies are doing
the feds crack down on it and set them
to prison because you're not allowed to
do that why don't we let the credit card
companies do the same thing well I think
part of what we're seeing is that a lot
of the financial services have really
been struggling to make money anywhere
because we've had these interest rates
pushed down so so so low and that
doesn't give those banks much room to
work to make money because right they
borrowed they take money from you into a
checking account and then they go lend
it out like a mortgage or something
right well those rates have been so low
that it's been tough for them to make
money so they've gotten desperate and
they've gone out further and further
into these these you know kind of edgy
activities just to try and make money
preying on the weak to bump their
margins up now finally what happens you
said interest rates low interest rates
this is one of the many unintended
consequences of Fed policy what happens
when they go up as they're going to yeah
well your credit card payments are going
to go up a lot higher as well they're
gonna be going faster and faster and you
look at what all this all this debt
that's outstanding and your payments
every month even if you don't add
anything more on to your credit card
your payments are gonna get more and
more expensive and at the same time it's
not like that income is growing really
fast so people find themselves just
further and further in the hole and if
we do get a recession which is gonna
happen right I mean we don't go
endlessly this is a normal cycle you
have booms in your bus that's a normal
thing to happen when it does happen how
are people gonna get through that's
exactly right and I'm ashamed to say
that I and a lot of other conservatives
had defended this crap for a long time
and we shouldn't have and we shouldn't
now so I appreciate the overview on that
thank you
well good to see ya